[Musique]
ce sujet de grief cause plus largement
la question de la prise en compte de la
parole des français dans ce débat à
l'image de vos recule contre un sur une
partie de l'augmentation de la csg pour
les retraités sur la taxe carbone sur le
coup de pouce au smic via la prime
d'activité sur vos 80 km/heure désormais
entendez-vous infléchir votre politique
économique et sociale si contestée où ce
débat ne sera-t-il qu'un exercice de
communication sans suite un certain
nombre de questions ont été posées
beaucoup 35 ou 36 je crois le
directement par le président de la
république dans sa lettre qu'il a
adressée aux français en répondant à ces
questions en s'exprimant sur ces sujets
les français vont nous donner un certain
nombre d'indications
il appartiendra ensuite au gouvernement
au parlement à l'ensemble de ceux qui
concourent au débat public d'en faire
leur miel de s'en inspirer dans la
réponse aux questions profondes et
anciennes qui taraude notre société
c'est dans cet esprit que nous nous
engageons et vous évoquez la question la
proposition qui a été formulée par
certaines organisations syndicales pas
toutes mais certaines qui a été
d'ailleurs reprise par certaines
associations d'élus d'organiser au terme
de l'exercice une grande conférence
territoriale et sociale qui permettrait
à l'ensemble des acteurs en question
d'échanger sur ce qui ressort du grand
débat et de le transformer le cas
échéant en propositions de solutions
c'est une bonne proposition
mutilé éborgné défiguré subissons
quotidiennement la violence symbolique
et sociales imposées par les politiques
gouvernementales c'est désormais dans
leur chair que sont frappées de nombreux
gilet jaune face à cette crise majeure
et à des rassemblement protestataire qui
ne sont celles par exemple parfois de
violence l'unique réponse apportée par
l'exécutive est une répression
disproportionnée plus de 5600
interpellations et gardes à vue plus de
mille condamnations ont le sens environ
3000 blessés dont 94 grave les violences
policières vont crescendo avec l' usage
d'armes toujours plus dangereuse
grenades de désencerclement flash ball
et autres lbd40 sans oublier le
tabassage et le gazage quasi
systématique
je tiens à rappeler le contexte dans
lequel se déroulent les manifestations
auxquelles vous faites allusion un
contexte de manifestations qui ne sont
jamais déclarait jamais encadré avec des
manifestants qui va parfois mais très
souvent s'en prennent de manière
extrêmement violente et agressive aux
policiers en leur jetant divers
projectiles et beaucoup nous disent
qu'ils ont sentiment plutôt qu'on
cherche à les tuer c'est dans ce
contexte là que s'organise et qui est
prévue la riposte policière mme la
sénatrice et uniquement dans ce contexte
là quand il ya des agressions ou quand
il s'agit de disperser d attroupement
violent
vous parlez des moyens intermédiaire de
défense effectivement les policiers
utilisent des grenades lacrymogènes des
grenades de désencerclement et parfois
quand ils sont vraiment acculé le
lanceur de balles de défense
mais encore une fois dans des conditions
très strictes et nous avons rappelé avec
christophe castaner à l'ensemble des
policiers ces conditions d usage et ses
conditions d'emploi et je peux vous dire
que si les policiers n'avaient pas ne
faisait pas usage de ses moyens de
défense peut-être que certains d'entre
eux auraient été lynchées comme nous
l'avons beaucoup vu nous avons beaucoup
vu des tentatives de lynchage des
membres des forces de l'ordre
et ça ça n'est pas acceptable et c'est
ça que nous voulons
vous condamniez
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]